so let me ask about
uh a complicated uh topic that's
sometimes a bit controversial which is
steroids
it may be uh trt testosterone
replacement therapy
what role does that play in strength
training all right
we're gonna uh we're gonna go there
let's go uh yeah
but it's an important discussion to to
have
um i think that uh it's something that i
can be
more transparent on um in my past i
wasn't
able to do to the career that i had so
just like
covering that stuff in a you know one on
a public forum
when you're highly looked at
being an executive for recruiting and
other stuff like
it was an area i had to just kind of
pass on right yes now i've used steroids
um i've used them since i was 33. 33
and i basically just used trt now
after my big squat so for 10 years
i used them and there's some interesting
uh components to this so um
one is just the the gray area of what we
call performance enhancing
supplements so uh performance was the
peds
um that the line of what defines a ped
is ever shifting and it's shifting based
on
society norms cultural norms government
bonding agencies all these sorts of
stuff so i'm not making excuses here so
i just want to
elaborate before i actually start
digging into the details here
because performance enhancing i could
take
sodium bicarbonate and
enhance my ability to perform deadlifts
for reps
guess what i did that for my guinness
world record for deadlifts in a minute
okay
people do it for rowing or other they
use high capacity
uh type stuff it is performance
enhancing
it is a chemical it is baking soda
all right um they're not able to make it
illegal because they
everybody eats bread well not everyone
and so it's a little hard to test for
no matter what you do at any level so
that's an extreme example
but other examples um you were drinking
a uh an energy drink in that
cup there a little while ago and in
america you can get an energy drink with
240 milligrams of caffeine in it
in canada that's too dangerous you can
only get 140
but you can go by ephedra and ephedra is
illegal in america
and so these things bounce back and
forth all the time
i could take yohimbi and in europe or
australia
it is a drug and classified in america
it's it is not it's a it's an herbal
root
uh and a lot i actually haven't won one
of my supplements except for the
overseas version
um anyway the point i'm getting is no
matter what
you do at some point there's by
someone's standards
you are cheating and
because it is you're taking something
that
but you could work around these things
with nutritional ways or other ways
versus taking a chemical structure and
there's a whole lot of ways to do this
but
it's like oh no it's steroids it's not
it's injectable it's not well
somewhere there's a culture or a person
that will say you're cheating no matter
what so it's a self-defined
you need to define it for yourself
unless you're competing in an
organization
that has testing then it's a straight
ethical
uh thing and it's either right or wrong
in my opinion
that's that's kind of the the overall
dilemma of it is
if you want to see what you're totally
capable of
you have to decide decide yourself
what's
okay or not to to that level there is no
there is no body that can say something
yes or no
yeah when there's an event like the
olympics maybe then
you have a standard that you're all
trying to adhere to
and then it makes sense to keep a
certain like to be within there's an
ethical there's an inheritance so yeah
i'm not talking about
that i'm agreeing to compete in this by
these by these rules yeah but when
you're trying to
maximize your own performance whatever
that journey is whatever that goal is
that's a different story and it's not
it's not easy to figure that out
you go oh you're just like dancing
around the subject whatever
well guess what i've got a i've got a
prescription for growth hormone and
testosterone
it's legal for me to take and you know
what
a lot of the people that are in front of
the camera in the media
politicians and news people and the
people that are there saying
the the no drug stuff they're going to
anti-aging clinics
to look better and they have a
prescription for growth hormone and
testosterone themselves
but in their eyes it's okay
it is a prescription from their doctor
because they have the money
to do it so it's legal and it's fine
if i it's interesting in oregon uh
anybody and i don't know what other
states um over the age of 16
can without parents permission by the
way walk into a gender clinic
and as a female and get a prescription
for testosterone
but as an athlete if i've got low
testosterone
i'm so flow i've got depression i
can't have sex with my wife it's
affecting my quality of life
i will have to fight tooth and nail to
get testosterone
just as a prescription and then i will
get kicked out of my organization for
competing
like so you understand how gray this
stuff gets do you think the stigma
on testosterone is the reason we're not
having like a healthy conversation about
when it's proper
like what are the proper uses of
testosterone in an athlete's life
in just the regular human life yeah
absolutely
i mean and it's just it's like anything
it's like i said it is lines that
we pick and draw anytime you put that
out there people are going to have
different opinions where those lines are
so now when it comes to strength here's
an interesting thing in powerlifting
there's tested federations and
non-tested federations so we can
literally look at the statistical data
and actually find out what do steroids
do
and so it's pretty clear that steroids
provide about a ten percent increase in
strength on
average over not now that does take out
the fact that steroids will put you in
uh allow you put on more mass so you'll
go up a weight class
a lot of times um so as a whole you
could definitely lift
more probably than the 10 over time
right and then we think about steroids
as the ability to just put on muscle
and here's where things get a little
interesting even with people that use
steroids is not understanding the
neurological impacts
that steroids have because you could
take some steroids
right now and be stronger in 10 minutes
that's clearly not done anything you
know from a physiology standpoint to
make you stronger
but we have a tapped in neurologically
to
to elicit those gains and there's a
whole lot that happens neurologically
like how much science is there
in terms of all the different ways you
could take steroids which kinds of
steroids the timing
the the dose the all of those things to
develop the
the neurological the physical the
skeleton like all all the
you know you've talked with such depth
about the science
of strength building in terms of
form uh in terms of the equipment that
you use
it seems like a component
you know the use of steroids should be
an equal
level of scientific rigor when applying
them it is
now the research is harder to to get
because of what it is but there is a lot
of research
that was done when they were legal um so
they were legal up in through the uh
through i think the mid 80s and so a lot
of the classical
high high benefit to low risk
steroids were studied and then since
then there's a lot of like designer
steroids or new steroids that have come
up that
don't have a lot of research around
safety and risk and things of that
nature and we can't do that because it's
you know because of the legality around
these things
but some of the stuff on the
neurological function is really
just understanding how that chemical
structure uh
works and what it's doing to the
neurotransmitters what it's doing
um and so some of it is
is really talking to people that have
experience with it
um and the other is understanding those
structures and what they do
the neurological component i think is
more interesting than
than most because the most steroids act
through increasing muscle protein
synthesis that's how you add more muscle
is they have an anti-catabolic effect
and they have a muscle protein synthesis
enhancing effect
so it reduces the amount of muscle that
you waste and increases the amount of
muscle that you put on
but the neurological component
is is tremendously valuable for what it
can do for your training
workout like if i handle more load over
time i'm going to make more progress
if i can actually just stimulate more
neurological effects for a specific
event
it's going to have an impact right but
there's other ways that you can tap into
this too
things that you can tap into mentally
with great practice with meditation and
other stuff that
will have the same effect people
probably think i'm overspeaking
especially
steroid users that are listening to this
at least i'm talking out my ass
but i'm not because i i uh
i have experience with this stuff um on
both ends and some of those areas a lot
of people don't have
uh the experience with that what i've
kind of
heard from people is the the confidence
that comes with steroids it feels like
not to call it placebo but it seems like
the psychological benefits of steroids
is huge
and that you feel like uh there's a
confidence
that seems to be uh coupled with the
actual biological and chemical effects
i have a actually a neurological
condition um so i actually don't
feel a lot of that stuff that people
because there's certain steroids that
like people will like
you're like very extreme ones um
like that would make somebody bite
someone's ear off in a fight for example
yeah
um aggression that and
they'll literally do nothing i'm like
always just chilling and mellow they
don't let god
uh but but neurologically they're still
having those effects but i don't get
those
feels that other people uh have from
but yes there's that immediate boost in
aggression and the confidence and stuff
that come with a lot of those ones that
deal on the neurological
um overall a good sense of well-being
just like from being on testosterone
like
it's going to affect your mood and it's
interesting so testosterone replacement
therapy
if we walk down that path knowing kind
of switch gears
you know we find that men today have
declining testosterone
over what has historically been in the
past so
right now i think a 35 year old
testosterone
is shown to be about half what it was
just 50 years ago so i don't know if
we could argue the point we don't really
have the science to validate any of it
but
it could be society as far as the impact
that it's having on the
mental uh health uh for men it could be
the
the estrogens floating around the water
from all the chemicals and birth control
and all this sort of stuff could be a
lot of things
um but it is the fact that average
testosterone is significantly lower
and that is going to end up affecting
life
quality of life as well as your
longevity because it will affect those
things but on the other end
steroids and trt particularly steroids
come with a lot of negative health
benefits
not benefits a lot of native health
ramifications
and so you know if i knew what i know
now
i don't know that i would have gone that
path i didn't i didn't tell i was 33
which is kind of an outlier for a
strength athlete um
i was i was a four times body weight
deadlifter 800 plus pounds at uh
198 and it's pretty dang strong
before i went down that path
and that's because i wanted to see what
i was capable of but i was reaching a
point that it was either
i need to do that or not my testosterone
my natural testosterone levels
were actually i think below 300 is
actually the threshold so i was being
told to go on trt for the last couple
years probably just because i was
pushing so hard and the stress level was
driving my test down
so it was self-imposed more than likely
but
i put it off because i wanted to set all
the drug-free records
and i set the ones that i wanted and
then it was 33 i'm
you know entering the age category and
i'm like i'm gonna go on trt
i did not feel like i should be with trt
personally my ethical standard was i
shouldn't be competing in tested events
anymore
um there are federations that will allow
you with your you show up with your
script and you do your test and you're
below a certain level but you're still
on
which but for me i'm like that's not
over you won't come so i'm like i may as
well at this point
use steroids um but
since then you know understanding all
those ramifications
uh you know i might not have gone down
that route quite so fast
and easily but i continued
because i also have a lot of resources
that other people don't in being able to
assess and understand and put things in
place to mitigate that so you need to be
and the other thing is once you go on
it's literally a decision for life
not neces but realistically is because
your your quality of life your feeling
is going to be enhanced quite a bit
and you're not going to want to go back
and if you go back it's going to be less
than it was before
that's how the endocrine system works
there are ways to try to recover and
bring that up but it might be a while
and if you've been on for a while it
definitely is not an option
so those are big things that people need
to understand that you're going to have
some things in there and even trt
has some potential especially with at
higher levels
that it's going to you know increase the
risk for prostate cancer
it's going to potentially cause some
hypertrophy of the left ventricle of the
heart and some potential
plaque buildup of the some of those key
arteries around there that's going to
have an impact on
your cardiovascular health there's
things that you can do
again but everything is like the shoe
story right where i'm anti
auntie shoe but i'm going well we can
put band-aids on this
yeah um so it's there's a quality of
life that comes with it the increase in
quality of life
and if you do it correctly i think and i
think for me for me i definitely would
not live without trt
even with knowing what i know now it
this
age and the quality of life and being
able to
be there have the energy the recovery
that's a big thing where all this though
i talked about muscle protein synthesis
and anti-catabolism as being big drivers
but recovery is the
other big aspect that they that they
offer probably as a result of those
but um that's gonna those are gonna be
the big enhancements so
um just doing steroids steroids is going
to
increase all the other stuff that you do
so if you've
if you have good training you have good
diet good quality of sleep like all this
other stuff
then you can take advantage of that but
you could shoot steroids and nobody
would know
and honestly you go down to 24-hour
business and you'll see a bunch of
you know late you know 19 to 21 year old
kids that are all kind of red and
150 pounds that look like that don't
look like anything
yeah and there a bunch of them will be
using steroids
because yeah they're not like so it's
it's not the it's not going to make a
champion like you said
it's not going to at most guess what i
was already at an elite level i was one
of the best in the world
before i started using it doesn't it
doesn't do that
it does a 10 increase at best yeah and
that's proven in the statistics which is
interesting because most people don't
know this like
it the data is right there yeah
yeah and that's why i i'm often saddened
by
maybe um the negative
view of somebody like lance armstrong
who's
one of the greatest athletes in history
and everybody else that he was competing
against i'm sorry
yeah i hate to blow anybody's bubble but
regardless if i told you my ethical uh
pieces with
saying that you're going to be at
something at an elite level
you look at most a lot of those big
figures out there
when the their income and your life
relies on it yeah you're going to push
those limits so
maybe maybe my ethical would change if
if if i was in that position too
because here's the thing what i believe
like
someone is i think people should avoid
steroids
trt probably something worth taking a
look at what your levels are when you're
in the 35 to 45 range
and see what decision you decide to make
from there and that's a decision that
you make for the rest of your life
the only times that you should be taking
a look at steroids is if it's
it's funding your life it's creating
that it is your job and it's doing
like and honestly it was for me
like i so was it the only thing
no no
you